i can't look i cannot watch this please
take the bit oh take the rook you
blunder's a rook
he's got he's got it queen f4 let's go
92
92 queen f4 please move make a move rook
v8 do something 50 seconds
make him no oh he blunders okay but
queen f4 he blunders i'm sure he
blundered this type of queen f4
queen f4 yes he sees it oh my goodness
queen before please take take see it see
it see no no no okay that's fine that's
fine
[Music]
the username's there then i'll just
start the the games
myself and then i'll be able to
alternate the colors for
for each match um so yeah i'll start the
games it'll be 3-0
and we'll start at the very top uh work
our way to the bottom fantastic i'll
also just do a quick recap on my end but
i think we're all set
i'm super yeah just did this also they
just rematched they can rematch
themselves
yeah okay uh that sounds great
all the uh you know official uh um stuff
out of the way yeah let's just
let's spill some blood let's freaking
let's fight
wonderful time is on
let's go
no commentary together this time that's
what we decided guys
but we are sweat streaming
no no window
wonderful time already better our guy is
already better look at this
this end game is bad guys the board is
working
all right here we go now
wonderful time is better he can just
leave the queen here enhancing the
pressure of the rook dna now if queen
takes d3 we taken
with the knight and we take the pawn
it's not entirely clear cut but the
knight also cannot move from a3 if
anything arises the board freezes let me
know
man i am so pumped guys i've been
looking forward to this all day i had a
really busy day
um i i had a crazy exhausting day
and i'm looking forward to this all
freaking day
and um thanks again everybody for coming
through i really appreciate this
community
i'll properly thank you later but
remember guys this is in good fun
trolling aloud you know encouragement
aloud please be respectful
of everybody who's putting themselves on
the line to play
um nobody is forced to play
so the fact of the matter is um
we have to appreciate each and every
person who decided to play put
themselves on the line this isn't easy
it's stressful
so let's be respectful let's be
encouraging and let's kick their butts
okay rook d7 here looks good white is
playing well this evil morty
character is uh he's no pushover i don't
i don't really like a wonderful time
okay rook d7 is good
i'm a little bit concerned about a3 here
a3 i'm slightly concerned about
well i guess our you know min can take
and go knight d5 i mean
uh yup he doesn't no he's very
underrated uh
our the chess bras that's there's no
doubt about that
they're very good at blitz knight a7
white might be better bishop e7
okay bishop b7 you sack the pawn you
have a beautiful knight on d4 he gives a
check on f4 instead and probably will
maneuver to d3
that's what min wants very concrete
approach
uh attacking the rook now rook t1
can min get something more than equality
out of this i think knight takes a seven
no but mid 90s knight a7 bishop c5 there
just knight a7 bishop c5 knight f2
winning
all right i'm gonna be strict with my
high-rated guys i'm gonna be strict with
them
min going for this now remember it's
three plus zero no increment that was a
terrible move
but men with a big time advantage um
i am going to be very strict with my
higher rated guys
um but with you know because i have very
high standards for
myself and for everybody else now black
is still better knight takes a seven
bishop c5 min can totally outplay
someone from this end game but i can
tell he's nervous
he needs to calm the hell down he's a
better player
and he needs to calm down and and play
his play his game right now king takes
d7 bishop c5 come on man play your game
play your game man bishop c5 there we go
get the king out
king king e7 and then rook c8 and just
out play him
roxy roxie rook c1 i i really i cannot
understand this move knight takes d5
okay rook c8 no but rook c1 i guess he
wants rook c6 but b4
he got he's got to get his bishop out of
there he has to get his bishop out of
there
i can just sense the anxiety but
rook c5 very good very good man knight
d6 rook c7
rook c5 come on man you've beaten you've
destroyed me and lost end games rook c7
man come on
there we go rook c6 don't let him get
anywhere near you f5 e5 and start
pushing the puns black is better here
f5 no there's no odds oh my goodness
okay this is a bit odd but okay black is
still better here f5 i mean he's got
more time
min should win this ten times out of ten
but he's he's playing nervous right now
b5
just like a russian school boy mustard
foose thank you for the raid my friend
party of 14 we are having battles with
the chess bras
with them on and of course i know that a
couple of you here
from the chest whereas huge shout out to
amman to eric
i'm not sure about this uh this might be
a winning pawn engine takes king d5 and
min is going to win e4 let's go man
let's get that passer going look at this
pawn on v5 that's the freaking hero it's
stopping both puns
and now g5 and f4 and it's over it is
over
red rover a3 or is it
oh it's close but a2 and it's over it's
over
let's go let's freaking go man
let's go f4 you get him you take it
you go f3 you win the game it's 1-0
ladies and gentlemen
it is one zero ladies and gentlemen just
as long as there
is no stalemates let's go push em baby
rock em cowboy all right queen d7 just
just
deliver check me boom let's go
let's go chess kid you are on deck
chess kid you are on deck get ready
please
let's frickin come in that's what we're
talking about
what an endgame that move b5 that was
the critical move
displaying the score in just a moment
guys the critical moment in the game min
playing b5
freezing the pawns and then the presence
of mind to go
into to go into a pawn end game
now that the pawns are restrained ladies
and gentlemen the score is 1-0
in favor of us wonderful time beating
evil morty let's go min
beautiful job chess kid against rue
lopez
got deported um
and tony get ready you are on deck after
chess kid ladies and gentlemen
here we go one zero is the score
fantastic job man fantastic job
okay
um i think we're ready i don't know what
the delay is
okay i'm just making sure i'm on and he
has everything he needs
yep and ladies and gentlemen it is
official
the score is one zero and we're on chess
kid is on
let's go let's go chess kid they don't
make him like him anymore we have an
english e4 yeah
that's what we're talking about
okay e5 bishop b4 is terrible e5 just
wins
e5 is okay come on jessica just go e5
and think later trust yourself go e5
trust yourself go e5
bishop b4 is a horrible move he's taking
way too long
on his move there we go
man congratulations you are the freaking
man you are the man
bc stop thinking and play move queen g4
if knight e4 queen g4
that is a no-brainer and he does it
white much better out of the opening
let's go oh yeah
well because we were black in the last
game
our guy our guy knows the english let me
tell you guys
our guy knows the english d4 knight f3
and look at the speed now
coming in with the speed
my volume is very low aquila can you
confirm that
my volume is low
i've raised it even further
knight f3 come on come on come on knight
f3 don't take don't you dare take the
pawn
knight f3
let's go it's good okay let me know if
it gets quiet or something i raised it a
little bit further
okay is it better now i raise the volume
all right bishop f4 dubrojovic
um i'm not sure but does it really
matter
voice is typically a bit lowish i mean i
really raised my volume up to the full
extent that it will go just get make a
goddamn move
move bishop f4 let's go he made it 49
stop thinking and move is it even
is it better at all
too slow he's got him he's got to move
fast e5 and queen moves away
okay it's incredibly meh got it
i keep raising it but
i'm talking like right next to the mic i
don't know what the problem is guys
sorry
i mean yeah i understand that roy but um
i don't know queen f3
gotta move the queen my only problem
with chesket is he's
there seems to be some lag time since
the time is very close what do you mean
okay so the volume doesn't get
any louder when i make it louder that's
interesting i've increased it the entire
way
um and i'm right next to the mic i don't
understand what the issue is guys sorry
okay you're just gonna have to put
headphones down but no but he's
completely let this go as chess kid
oh no queen e4 is not the way don't go
into the end game but maybe you do maybe
bishop takes c4
what about the gain maybe i should turn
the gain on rookie b1
word is frozen no it's not seriously
ambiak
rook ab1 let's go attack the pawn it
goes
e1 i don't like them but rook b1 just
attacking the pawn much stronger
but this is okay rook b1 oh rook b1 is
oh he's got to go bishop c8 now
c5 then look at the bishop on d6 that'll
be protected black is thinking he's
hitting into his clock
chess kid is the man he just found rook
b1 that's a huge move
that's a huge move now the pawn on b7
yup c5
cementing the bishop on c5 yep
all right guys please move on from the
volume i will fix it put on headphones
raise the volume on your computer and
live with it
uh rook b1 back look at this man go
hey ruja
oh look at the time look at the time
ladies and gentlemen look at the time
cb okay that's a really strong move
though bishop e4 is very good here i
think
bishop bishop before maybe bishop takes
c2 he's got to play fast he's got to
keep the time advantage and flag the
heck out of him
a4 come on make a move just make a
decision make a decision
cb just take on passant okay he goes
bishop b4 good good good
okay a4 there we go breaking through
just playing f4 f4
f4 rook a1 oh even better he's coming
into a7 look at the compensation for the
pawn look at these bishops
the king is weak rook a7 caught on the
crossfire he's got to watch the pawn f4
he gets the king and i like it
just keep bleeding some clockovich keep
bleeding some clock of itch bishop f4
don't release the tension just like we
talked about let's go rookie seven
rookie seven make a move stop thinking
and move
stop thinking and move
oh my god make a move okay good move
rookie seven
rook b7 stopping the pawn don't take it
king e2 is really good
take the maybe it's just taking oh it
should be five can you see two good
he's up 10 seconds 14 seconds just
returning flagging
flag him okay
flag him yeah baby
okay sorry i got excited chess kid
coming through we're up to zero
ladies and gentlemen okay don't repeat
just do something with a pawn okay oh
just
just just okay okay that was made in one
and chess get wins
we got him again we got him again
with a beautiful opening and then
delivering there were ups and downs in
this game
but a great decision to go into an
endgame chess kid wins we are up 2-0
who is hype right now at this start
who is hyped right now at this start
i mean this is just there's just nothing
to it there is nothing to it
all right chess kid with a win and
tani tani on deck tony one of the great
prodigies right now
tanya you ready get ready tawny to
deliver
a third blow it's 2-0 ladies and
gentlemen the score is up
a flaps are down all chambers are filled
tonight
tony get ready all of the chambers
filled
okay there we go and they have begun
okay and we have tony with the black
pieces against cardisco
and white already thinking and tawny
with a c5
hitting him with a c5 okay so we have
an accelerated dragon tony's bread and
butter
he's an accelerated dragon kind of guy i
like it d6 bishop d7 this is all theory
it's got an early time advantage i like
it
okay this is all theory what are we
watching here we are watching sub
battles
eyes all right a6 or a5
are both good a5 knight takes d4
anything is fine here
rookie 8 is a move yeah just sort of
preparing e65 but you got to be careful
a6 or a5 now this is a very very bad
move now knight b5
sadly this is a very bad move but let's
see if white finds knight b5
this is not good he's got to go d5 and
sack the exchange and go d4 yeah
nice he does do it now if knight d6
that's that would be a blunder due to d4
okay d4 tony let's go puzzle rush you've
solved problems harder than this d4
bishop takes the 494 and
he's going to lose an exchange but he's
in the game he's going to lose an
exchange but he's in the game
freaking hit him with that d4 hit him
with that d4 take your time curtis go
take your time
now here's the thing bishop takes d4 you
don't want to take because then white
takes and you don't really have a
discovery and you're going to lose an
exchange
so the best move here would be to take
on e4
and then look at this beautiful bishop
maybe just drop it to e5
and you could even go queen h4 just go
for the direct attack
he does do that and he does it instantly
which is awesome
tani sees this stuff freaking while
skydiving
he sees this while he's skydiving
he sees this while he's freaking
skydiving
okay now he's up a minute let's see what
he does
there should be five uh yeah
frozen again no okay
now this bishop oh but f4 oh he's gonna
lose another exchange though this is not
good takes e594
take up take the knight go e5 and then
knight d4 he'll find it he will find it
takes takes e5 knight comes to d4 he's
got compensation or
you could sack a second exchange okay
he's gonna do it yep
e5
knight d4 let's go white is still much
better but tony
bishop c6 rook c6 is also possible
just got to do something here keep the
time advantage is what's going to win
black the game here
okay
so i guess knight f5
guys nobody is listening um our people
are honorable
please don't uh imply that just because
he finds a good move he's listening now
he's getting outplayed rook d1
white is is playing incredibly well
incredibly well 96 but he's still alive
no he actually white is playing
incredibly well knight e6
but black is still alive with 40 seconds
on the clock
yep tiny does it and pre-moving
so he's got to get white low on time low
queen wow
c5 and bishop c4 man this guy is
incredibly good
and kardiska even beat him on recently
queen a5 maybe
yeah this is this is this is just losing
queen h4 queen h4
he's gonna find it he's gonna find it
i'm not even suggesting good moves by
the way he does it
um there's also delay guys no
you literally could not listen because
there's too much to like queen d4 queen
v4 or something like this
yeah queen b8 though queen b a queen e5
but
it's going to be close buckle up buckle
your seat belts white is
losing queen d2 whatever queen summer
takes c5
maybe take c5 and then just go into the
end game flag flag
flag come on tani queen b4 keeping the
queen on the board yeah
take the pawn and flag okay he keeps the
queens on the board that makes sense now
white has perpetual
but he's burning clock he's burning into
his clock
ladies and gentlemen 14 he's not moving
holy smokes what is he doing oh my
goodness
eight seconds okay tony yeah now queen
d5 what a move
he see the presence of mind to say all
right i'm gonna trade queens now
oh and this man this man's got it he has
ice in his veins ladies and gentlemen we
are up 3-0 oh you take that pawn
with check you come around to e5 you
take on c4 and on d6 and it collapses
and he's winning and he wins
and there we go oh tony the hero
3-0 oh my lands what a game
very well played by white very well
played but tawny stuck around
several very nice ideas including that
sacrifice
getting the knight to d4 keeping the
queens on the board bleeding out white
squawk and finally winning all of
white's pieces
well done sir three zero
three easier that's what we're talking
about that's how we start a freaking sub
battle all right
that's how we stop that's how we start a
subtle minute you begin
freaking revolution here 3-0
ankle ankle on deck and cole 36
are you in the chat are you in life
chess
and cole 36 please announce yourself
we had a hard time finding a 1900
uh and cole please announce yourself
you're live perfect
get ready and call you got this playing
against dashing tangos ankle 36 and then
chewie on deck
chewie is on deck all right guys
we freaking got this this is what we
came here for
this is what we came here for i do need
to run to the restroom
all right cool
the sober team well we came prepared all
right
oh they already started sorry here we go
we have a london system
we got a london system all right i'm
gonna be after this
this game oh hg white's already better
oh look at this file oh 95.
bishop h7 might actually even be close
to winning but no
95 i would well or i could defend the
pawn with rook b1 yeah yeah just
level-headed okay
oh man playing the london against the
braz taste of their own medicine
e d always yep ankle knows what he's
doing
95 what is this it's just 95 don't be
afraid
d e or 95 are both fine i mean
i i don't know 95 and i don't i see a
move for black because black can't move
his knife from f6 for example
if you do this thinking i've got knight
g4 well you blunder the pawn and then
you're gonna have a devastating
discovery
he's taking too long but he takes on e5
with the knight look at the man go
if you go rook e8 you support it with f4
you support it with f4 that's going to
be very important this happens
guys we might score a quick knockout
here knight e4 is forced okay now i have
four
but then queen e3 you got to watch out i
guess knight f3 is better
or even queen e2 just don't go f4
because that's actually a very bad move
due to queen e3
queen e2 is the move as men confirms
yeah
easy you'll find it he'll find it he
realizes that yep
ankle realized something was amiss and
he plays queenie two
this is actually quite complicated but i
think i have faith in our guys we just
need to deliver
oh and he gives the pawn and f4 i mean
just take the pawn
or maybe just go okay so he does
and then maybe knight f3
or maybe f4 i mean one of the two moves
is forced
i think just f4 hmm
ford g6 is complicated though
does go knight f3
f6 i guess bishop g he goes g6 no black
is very strong
windy two maybe
maybe queen d2 or rook d1 i don't know
something like that
stroke d1 he's taking a little too much
time though
i don't know rook t1 something like that
yeah this has gotten a little bit hairy
for white
this has gotten a little bit hairy for
white he's he's too slow
okay he castles but king g7 is very
strong
yeah i can see what amman was saying
about their guys being underrated
jesus this guy has drawn them on beaten
rudolf i don't know
queen d2 oh and he collapses no
that's gonna be our first loss that's
sad what a great
off to a great start was ankle but
collapsing here with his pieces that
bishop on h7 got trapped and
barring a miracle but this tango is is
just way too strong
yeah he's okay well fair enough
all right chewie you got this all right
guys i need to run to the restroom this
game is over
unfortunately it's all good ankle keep
your head up high i will follow you
chewie i'll be right back guys
i'll be right back
oh rook h1 that's dirty that's dirty
good game ankle keep your head up high
we're up 3-1 no worries we can take this
chewy chewy's gonna
shade time let's go chewie you got this
my friend you got this chewy
and they're on g6 this chewy knows the
accelerated let me tell you guys he
knows the accelerated
castle yeah
oh yeah chewy
now chewie is an accelerated expert you
don't mess with him in the accelerated
dragon you just don't mess with him in
this line
do not mess with him in this line
i think queen a5 or rook b8 is good
you just don't mess with him in this one
queen a5 chewie come on
oh rook b8 we need five
he knows this let me tell you guys he
knows this all right tawny
great game have a great night thanks
again for playing tony you're the man
rook b8 now oh but now knight d5
oh but okay you can go queen oh no
knight t5
talked about this um rook b8 instead is
is just a no-brainer you've got to put
the
the idea being rook b8 knight takes d5
rook takes b2
and knight e4 oh
of course he founds it finds it no now
it's losing
that's not a blunder that chili should
be making
it's just not a blunder you should be
making rook b8 now maybe but
there's there's no chances anymore
another
underrated guy i guess
how do you not play rook v8 there i
don't understand stroke b
the king moves to the b fall you put the
rook on b8 should be six just
overthinking it
okay knight d7 i like though trying to
open up the diagonal
okay this is not a great move rook b8
now
but then b3 i guess simply
i'm pretty bummed that was a great
beginning i
hyped it up too much
okay good move
it's not over no he's a resilient
he's resilient it's far from over i mean
black has active pieces the problem is
the three pawns down is just too much
material
but uh no it's never over but white is
just too accurate knight a4 maybe
knight a4 let's go
i'm just a little bit bummed you didn't
play rook b that would have almost been
game right there
you have a bishop d4 which white will
find in about three
two one
um no i guess not he keeps thinking yep
of course
sure he does have heart brook ca just
got to stay in the game somehow why does
this
yeah you need to play fast and you need
to try to create problems
you need to make it into a time scramble
and then it's anybody's game but
rook d8 i would go the problem is white
takes and goes c3 but at least make him
find it
or rook b8 i mean just do something
rook b8 yeah he's gonna go b3 probably
chewie's gotta chew he's good at bullet
too he's gotta he's gotta find it in
himself to play fast
he is better than than uh bell cult at
bullets so with one minute on the clock
he's taking a long time here
all right guys this is something this is
freaking something
okay now okay good rook c8 get your
pieces to active squares
fast chewy fast play fast
let's go rook c8 okay under a minute for
white now
under a minute for both this is chewie's
game right now i'm telling you he's down
three pawns
but but he's got active pieces look how
much time white is taking on every move
look at how much time white is taking
okay move the rook too we move the real
quickly
stop thinking
okay fast ah
move king g7 gotta get gotta get out of
rook d8
king g7 no-brainer
yeah let's go let's go he's got heart
this man has heart
this man has freaking heart and he's
forcing white to think he's vacuuming up
some time here yeah every passing second
let's go 35 count it down 434
he's going to be under 30 seconds and a
10 second advantage for chewie
white has made zero progress toward
winning this game
zero he hasn't pushed a goddamn pawn
he hasn't pushed a goddamn pawn yet
let's go knight b6 two more seconds off
the clock three more off the clock four
five six off the clock 20 seconds take
it and go h5
push the puns go fast chewy let's go
best
yeah knight c4 force him to think okay
that's not a great trade rook c4
don't trade rooks though do whatever you
do do not trade works 14 16 15.
okay king f6 whatever just move do not
freaking trade rooks yeah keep the
bishop on the board that's freaking
right
you keep the bishop 11. rook c7 just
count it up bleed the clock don't give
up the rook let's go guys
guys bishop b6 just chewy please
go fast don't give me a freaking heart
attack here king f6
a5 he's stopping before take it take the
pun
take the pawn chewie
okay he's got to start pre-moving he has
a mouse for it chewy
move your ass
move move chewie come on pre-move
pre-freaking move pre-move
oh my god move ah
move free move every move has to be
pre-moved
i don't i mean
that was an incredible comeback but
chewie you have got to pre-move when you
get to three seconds
ah very close
so here rook b8 was the move
knight takes d5 rook takes b2 check
and 94 but
it's just and it's i understand
i understand the anxiety but
everyone here when you reach five
seconds
it doesn't freaking matter what move you
make you just have to pre-move
that's just you just have to do it uh
you have to force yourself to do it
um and and whatever it takes
you have to force yourself to free move
it doesn't matter what move you make
literally rook h1 rook h2 rook h1
anyways that was an amazing comeback i
mean you stayed in there with three puns
down
keep your head up that was a great game
fantastic fight
um we'll we'll be better next time but
we're still up a point so let's be very
clear here we're still up a point
okay so uh unconventional you're up next
unconventional we've got a juggernaut up
next
all right ready he says ready and he is
ready
all right
it's all good we got this
unconventional is playing here we go
all right guys we gotta stop the
bleeding we gotta stop the bleeding
sorry guys if i can get bitter i'm
really rooting for
people i care i care about our team
that's just the russian way of rooting
for people
okay so we've got a car con without four
that's a typical line
i guess castles or no don't go bishop b3
though
castles just castle okay queen b3 is
fine
those of you who don't know
unconventional is a longtime supporter
of my stream
many months now amen is awesome
and he's an incredible tactical player i
don't know why he took the queen though
he should not have taken the queen now
this is coming in somehow all of the
bras
regardless of their rating they just
know all of the plans in every position
before
yeah it's already a lot it's already
very bad for white bcb5 is the move
or h5
they're well trained they know
i mean i like i like h3 though he's
trying to create
opportunities on the king side of g4
okay g4 g4 yeah okay that white black
should not have allowed this now white
is chances
okay now maybe uh see
okay so he takes but now night before a3
knight c2 no that was not a good move he
should have kept the tension
maybe bishop d1 okay knight c2 rook
a2 and then knight c6 is extremely nasty
but let's see if black finds it
okay
so now i mean the knight is annoying but
knight b1 knight c3 is a
unconventional type of maneuver i think
he would enjoy this
okay tries to trade
now get the knife back that's right
defend the bonnet damage
sorry guys she's connecting my mouse
here
oh yeah now he brings his king and look
at the time no nobody's sniping guys
nobody's sniping we're all adults here
nobody's typing
we are honorable oh
this is close though one minute for
black unconventional is staying alive
here i don't see an exact
way for black i guess takes in rock f1
yeah knight see the maneuver that i
would do here is knight b1 knight c3
just
basically blockading everything okay he
takes
now i would defend the spawn with the
king king e3 yeah
take it in 91 knight f3 get get this
knight go and get this knight working
okay but now but don't don't move the
knight unconventional do not move the
knight
please don't move the knight okay g5
he's making inroads he's going for a win
g-h okay this looks like a draw king g4
this does look like a draw please don't
move your knight
okay but now white is in trouble because
he somehow found this idea of 97
97 he's got to get back get back
unconventional get back
and if 97 93 he's staying alive for now
but
of course no no no no king f3 king
freaking f3 don't let him
get through don't let him get through
king f3 is a no-brainer
there's literally no other legal move in
the position other than king f3
i don't i honestly don't know what he's
thinking about
okay i guess he want oh he wants this
but it's too passive 97 black is winning
but
time situation oh
okay but now it takes oh passer
passer alert king e3
c3 yeah
see take it take it take it take it 91
stop the pun and then go go with your
king
king f4 maybe okay oh my god
how does mike find this king b4 no
no no he's not going to stop it
oh my goodness all right
knight d2 try to go for the um the fork
it's not over yet knight c4 though
can you see three knight b3 you got to
keep the knight
okay he's going the wrong way don't go
to c2 again
okay wait a minute now run to c3
unconventional run and take the knight
against e5 let's go let's go that's
right you pre-move
ah yeah you push a baby
move move
whoa oh my goodness
oh my lands oh my lands
literally what you are is a hero
that is literally what you are i mean
that is unbelievable
can you freaking believe this we might
make more mistakes in the bras but
we have spirit we have resilience
and we do not die
okay oh my goodness that was crazy
um unconventional winning riding the
ship we're up by two again assass
you are next jack sore attacking
juggernaut
is next omni thank you ah well thank you
so much for the 16 months here we go
here we go here we go
we do have the flagging on our side
amazing unconventional deserved
absolutely
and here we go
we have our guy jack sir
okay bishop g7
oh my god you blurted a rook
oh he blundered her rook and that sniper
on g7 how many games have we won with
that bishop let's go
now he's just got to take this home take
this home jackson h five's a good move
take on h
yeah you trade the other rook queen take
oh move the pawn
d5 come on jackson see it see and see a
knight of six with temple let's go
oh yeah we smell blood ladies and
gentlemen
we can ex we can push this up to three
again if we can take this one home don't
take with a queen okay
don't take the pawn actually you can
even take the fungal roche rook g2
white lost it we ate it up
okay jackson just be confident here just
yep good
amazing move amazing move
just get the queen out of there is what
he's saying
unconventional that was incredible okay
now
just go knight e5 or take the pawn
anything really just literally anything
wins
yeah you push him away you come to g3
you take the pawn
yeah this is this is crushing up a rock
and attacking
i mean jaxer i'm telling you is this guy
can attack
i i've known him for a while this man
okay 1668 it's a modest rating
but let me tell you this guy can attack
and he can find good squares for his
pieces knight f4
knight f4 see it see it look at the
whole board yep he takes on c5 good move
too
have g just take back take the pawn
yep
knight f4 yeah look at the speed he said
i'm
dropping that bishop in there bishop
before knight f4
i'm dropping that bishop in there
okay you can take on c2 with check you
can go knight f4 anything is good here
bishop e5 even i mean bishop i would go
bishop e5 and bishop g3
let's see what he ends up doing
but you got to do something here okay
oh vision d3 see it see it you've got a
million force here you can win the queen
you can literally okay he does this
which is fine
take the pawn and then trade queens
jacks or trade queens
just trade them get rid of yeah
i mean look at the technique is take
with the pawn yeah stop the knight from
developing
okay rook v8 doesn't matter bishop c
bishop d7 okay oh but the night is
the night is trapped the night is
trapped
look at this the knight is just trapped
and then once you take the night the
bishop is gonna be trapped
dubrov maybe phone
literally the knight and the bishop is
trapped
oh he's taking it all he's vacuuming it
up
yeah this is resignable i mean i don't
know what he's
what jax was thinking about take
something yeah
this is a crushing game i mean he is
literally that's freaking right jaxer
that is what a game and this line with
a3 white should go bishop b2 first
white rushed with that move
amazing game and we are up by three i
mean
just look at these knights just boom
boom boom boom
boom boom i just everything was gone
amazing game
all right so we are up by three ladies
and gentlemen
do do lu dulu get ready dulu
dolu 33 get ready you're on deck or
sorry you're up dulu 33 you got to be in
live chess
dolo i don't see you you need to get
into life chess
right now uh dolu dolu 33
doofu sorry oh it's doofy i didn't read
it properly
oh it's an f okay sorry sorry i thought
it was dolu
because i'm looking through my stream
and he's playing already here we go
sorry sorry sorry it's an f okay here we
go our guy is white we are up
ladies and gentlemen we are up by three
let's take this home
what do we say let's take this home
oh they're they're they're not gonna be
happy when we freaking demolish them
right now
we're not we're not letting them back
into this match let's go
duffel only f is for the bras that's
right
okay now they take on d4 though i don't
like this
the score guys is five to two in our
favor
okay bishop now what black these are
good
these guys are underrated
knight takes d4 and queen f3 don't trade
queens don't trade queens
you're down upon don't trick queens just
like your mama tie you queen f3
surgical indeed mark i agree bishop oh
he can take
see it okay rook d1 now he can take you
can take
because if you take on c6 boom and it's
a forkovich
will he see it he's he spotted something
he's gonna find it this is an easy
tactic easy
easy tactic he saw it he's like i'm not
letting that king
castle that's how they do it here in
charlotte
let's freaking go guys
we gotta take this home right now we we
gotta put them the freaking
frick away guys uh
we're not gonna bring it up oh my no no
no
no no no no no no
you no a bishop queen defends the bishop
now you got to move the queen away it's
not over yet we've seen
we don't die that's that's a spirit
shared by everybody no i don't care it's
okay
black is far from out of the woods here
for example
this is already an inaccuracy now bc
queen e4 queen d6
okay now rugby one you got to just start
harassing black
players do not listen to stream guys
nobody wants that nobody does it
this is all in good fun we're playing
for 20 subs no but why are you training
queens
no don't trade queens when you're down a
piece okay i mean i i understand what
he's saying
what doofu is saying is that oh bishop
d5 is such a good move
queen a4 i would drop it i would just
drop it back
that's freaking right doofu he senses it
he says no no no i'm not giving you
another chance c4 and rook d7 come on
easy
okay what is c4 c4 just chase attack
too slow well black is definitely
playing better than 15 90.
he's 2 000 bullet is white is black
how do they find these people we in d4 i
guess no but this is
sadly we are a bit outmatched here
sadly we're just a bit outmatched here
yeah this is a loss but that's okay
because guess what we won the last three
and bishop f3 he's not even taking the
rook i mean
this guy is this guy is good this guy's
the real deal
okay but
queen c5 queen c1 i guess
i think i'd have a competitive game
queen d5 okay queen c6
just trading queens
yeah all right that's a good effort by
do for now
uh on deck is uh dubroyevich de
bruyjevic you're on deck
guys we need our laura have to step up
drink your coffee have your espresso and
uh deliver you deliver guys you got this
that's okay
okay that's okay good game good effort
just that bishop takes b7 that's what
did you win so it's five to three that's
the score
we got this guys red bull energy drink
whatever you freaking
whatever you ingest to
to play better finish your espresso
concentrate here we go
okay so we got dubroyevich dubrovic is
up next
it's okay you got this
let's go to brevitch represent
and against loudly pawn
alright say your prayers
king's indian d6
yeah again another freaking london
yeah but black is not playing this well
just b5 we need to win this game well we
don't need to win anything we're still
up two points
problem is it's the system i mean you
know all the moves in it
now white is much better let's see how
he finds it though finally we get a
fresh position
just playing all the right moves bishop
d7 black is passive but very solid i
mean it's hard to break this through but
queen d2 bishop h6
in c2 okay he's preparing this may be
interesting
it's okay dude you played well that was
a beautiful tactic
you're good man
97 95 is interesting he goes five he
says take me
now taking that's a mistake this guy i
understand that white wins a pawn
okay he doesn't even take the pawn i
could even consider taking
and going bishop d5
bishop d5 come on see it see it deprevic
okay fine
okay this is black is worse but it's not
clear bishop d5 yeah
you got it okay white is again playing
very well
rogue bd8 i would go
okay that's a good move just reinforcing
the pawn here
guys i know it's oh but don't take don't
please don't take
because of rook takes d5 yeah trust me i
know how nerve-wracking this stuff is
h6 prepare yeah because i put
i haven't played that many team
tournaments actually but i did play the
world team championships 2015.
that feeling when three of your
teammates have drawn
and you're the fourth board and the
results of the match hangs in the
balance i've experienced that too and
i've lost
i have takes g4
no but look at how white is playing why
does playing like a solid 17 1800
very impressive very impressive play
queen e3
wow what a move not three capturing
okay maybe g5 though how good is it yeah
rocket trade is good
rook ba maybe you gotta get the rook
involved but
i'm just worried that yeah
this is a tough position to defend
oh bishop h1 and instantly
being four
white is attacking like a seasoned
veteran
bishop h6 don't tell me he finds this
even rook h if he finds rook h5
rook h5 is made okay he trades queens
but he's still winning that's the issue
his positions are so
winning that anything wins
okay h7
g8 guys
we're gonna have to step it up here i'm
just gonna be i'm gonna be russian
charlie coach straight up with you guys
stop thinking about the fact that
they're underrated all of you are
capable of winning
stop hesitating and step it up
and you guys got this i believe in you
yeah this is
over for page six or f8 wow
incredible play by white incredible play
by white
um but congrats congrats okay so we're
only down
we're up by one we're still up all right
uh drop kick
you you better deliver the dropkick
right now four to five this is a big
game
dropkick you got this
calm cool and collected drop kick has
us drop kick you got us
focus on the game put away all
distractions
focus focus focus you got this we
we were dead we were up by one earlier
and we won two that's what we're gonna
do again
okay
you're not bad at all you actually
played really well to brevis you found
some really nice ideas i was
particularly impressed
i was particularly impressed f5 was
really good
so the way you over protected that one
king g7 was a really nice idea honestly
if i'm honest with you your opponent
played incredibly well
alright we got dropkick against vowelly
from finland
and we got an amazing position out of
the opening here dropkick is our secret
weapon he's got this
he's acting he's just sipping on a pina
colada right now
sipping on a pina colada developing his
pieces like a boss
developing his pieces like a bus thank
you guys everybody
635 people this evening joining us
for sub battles with the chess bras and
a huge shout out to the trespass of
course
um but everybody who is playing cheering
on
i really appreciate it i really
appreciate it
uh you guys are amazing
okay bishop h4 or take either anything
is good here
grandpa gifting to pot of green and
speaking of that everybody who
subscribes
who supports who gifts who
encourages who roots um
is an integral part of the community and
i appreciate it
greatly um okay so queen a592 i guess
white is much better my voice is going i
have spoken for like 12 hours today
come on man my boy chest get gifting 2
yb525 into chest full
thank you just get winning with an early
game white is much better now an idea
here
typical idea is to get this knight
around to e4
get this knight around to e4
just a very typical maneuver here i
think
you should know it h4 maybe
okay bishop b4 is good yeah but black is
again starting to play really well
you're developing perfectly he goes 92
now
knight b3 maybe i have a feeling this is
coming down to the wire again bishop d3
okay castle's white is better
yeah i've had a blast and we have a lot
of
amazing people here a4 start attacking
well knight takes c4 bc rook fb1 maybe
or a5
well i do x a b come on man a b come on
man
a b rook takes a seven see it see it see
it see i see it
see it see it's here hey b come on come
on drop kick yeah
freaking god is a boss this man is a
boss queen takes d2 rook a7
just take it back stop stop thinking
don't overthink it yeah
take it and black's king is falling
apart here my only concern is he's got a
minute 11 seconds
you're ugly i'm spent and i have to move
i have to turn
in the keys to my old apartment tomorrow
and i have movers coming in the morning
i have a million things to move
and i've been going since 9 00 am and
it's 10 p.m
so yeah tough sunday but
we'll see look at this c4 c4 let's go
you push him away you push that knight
away
he's going to find it i believe him yeah
that's right it's freaking right
bishop takes p7
and c5 this is easy
yeah i actually will be moving furniture
around in the middle of the night
moving is such a pain it's just such a
pain
we take c5 i guess but dc
and i got like not a lot of sleep so i'm
on my last legs here
but we'll see queen takes c5 this is
reinvigorating me i have to say
the energy is reinvigorating me
take the night my friend take the
freaking night you take the night
don't overthink it take the night come
on move
now take stakes just start pre-moving
start playing fast rook b6 don't
overthink it
take the pawn just take it okay he wants
the oh
king b7 though he allows just move it
back or take the rug do something
i'm afraid of the time the clock is what
really is worrying me here
okay you want to trade queens that's
fine pre-move though
okay make a little yeah good exactly h3
is good
okay he's up a couple of seconds but
he's got to start moving
see our guys that's my one criticism you
just got to start moving yeah
that's that's what we call speed oh but
okay take sweeney seven now oh he sacked
it he saw that
queen d6 okay queen d5 is almost made
queen e5 queen b5
find it find it find it queen b5 that's
freaking right take the rook just take
the rook take the rook free moving
look at the king this might be a big one
guys queen a3 yeah
just move something do it ah trade
queens he's gonna pre-move
he's gonna win he's gonna win 11 seconds
four seconds three
take the pawn just give it up for it
don't stalemate move fast remove
everything
don't stale mate please don't stale mate
pre-move
you gotta pre-move don't that's it just
move your finger
oh my god oh oh
yes
[Music]
oh my goodness me drop kick
and who doubted it even for a second
who doubted it even for a second
nobody doubted it for a second that
green right there that's what we that's
what we do
that's what we do in this house dropkick
extending the lead to two with five
games
remaining aj saunders you got it